well the big screen is back regal las
vegas largest cinema chain
opened the doors of more than three
locations today after months and months
of shutdowns
as sasha loftus found out it is just
another sign of our city's
economic rebound after months of
closures
and uncertainty movies are back on the
big screen
it's been forever to come to movie
theaters film fans
are also back in full force as many
flock to regal cinemas
for its reopening inside boulder station
on friday
i'm happy to be out of the house the
nationwide chain which operates
nearly a dozen locations here in las
vegas
is one of many corporations rebounding
after a year of economic struggles
connected to kovitt 19. the buzz is not
just with tourists and
locals going back to establishments but
it impacts the whole ecosystem
for for southern nevada las vegas urban
chamber of commerce chair shondell
newsome says reopening locations like
this
also brings more people back to work it
really has a as a
a greater impact than most people
understand
and i know there are a lot of big chains
and big
huge theater chains but there are some
small ones independently on
theaters that have been greatly impacted
as well in the small business market
so if you've been dreaming of that
classic
cinematic experience it may be time to
venture out
and see what our revitalized valley has
to offer
open up your life and start again you
know get things going again
like all other theaters in the valley
regal is following cdc
guidelines so masks are still required